aquí
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia la han atravesado cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de hacinamiento o
de marginalidad o se veían obligadas a
migrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo
comenzamos esta semana en palestina
donde se cumplieron 20 años de la
denominada segunda intifada en jerusalén
un levantamiento popular de los
palestinos en contra de las fuerzas
israelíes que abrió un nuevo capítulo
sangriento en el medio oriente
actualmente los jóvenes palestinos miran
con preocupación el paralelismo de lo
que pasa actualmente con lo que pasaba
hace 20 años una frustración con sus
propios líderes y con el desvanecimiento
de algún día pertenecer a un estado
propio palestino
la mezquita de al-aqsa en la ciudad
vieja de jerusalén fue el escenario
donde el 28 de septiembre del año 2000
estalló un conflicto con piedras y gases
lacrimógenos la chispa que encendió la
confrontación fue la visita del político
israelí ariel sharon a la mezquita
considerada uno de los lugares sagrados
para el islam pero detrás estaba la
enorme frustración por la promesa de un
estado palestino que nunca se llevó a
cabo
cuando se firmó el acuerdo de hoy no se
le dijo al pueblo palestino de una
manera muy simple que si creían en las
negociaciones obtendrían un estado
propio
pero cuando verán que las conversaciones
en campo deivid no dieron resultado y
cuando ariel sharon irrumpió en la
mezquita de al-aqsa el pueblo palestino
estaba enojado y se sintió decepcionado
de que después de tantos años no
tuvieran nada
hernani a sus 33 años para el joven ziad
abu sayad el estado palestino que ha
buscado toda su vida todavía parece tan
lejano como estaba en ese entonces sobre
todo porque los recientes acuerdos de
paz entre israel y los emiratos árabes
unidos y bahrein son considerados una
traición para la causa palestina
creo que vivimos en una situación muy
similar a la ocurrida previamente la
segunda intifada donde hay desesperación
que hay un gran fracaso cuando se habla
del proceso político y si creo que el
pueblo palestino necesita ser
inteligente y pensar sabiamente antes de
elegir el camino porque queremos ir
detrás de ubuntu dentro
otra joven palestina que recuerda la
segunda intifada es la antigua una mujer
de 24 años que experimentó los tiros los
ataques suicidas y los tanques de guerra
un conflicto que dejó más de 3.000
palestinos y mil israelíes muertos
[Música]
durante la intifada muy bien y fue
bastante difícil todos mis recuerdos de
niña dan la vuelta a la intifada y
recuerdos felices son jugar con balas
balas vacías y recuerdos tristes son ver
a mi papá siendo utilizado como una
armadura humana de mis recuerdos
normales son tener una llamada con mi
mejor amiga solo porque los estados
israelíes activan en su casa
así que fue algo
esta generación de jóvenes palestinos es
reacia a visitar de nuevo el trauma de
la intifada aunque no se han rendido a
la esperanza de tener un estado propio
ven con pesimismo que hoy por hoy se
logre a través de una lucha política
vamos a afganistán donde ser mujer
conlleva una larga lista de
restricciones más aún en la provincia de
kandahar al sur del país donde yace el
bastión conservador junto al grupo
militante islamista talibán para estos
hombres las mujeres deben cuidar al
extremo sus maneras y el uso de la burqa
en público pero una activista defensora
de los derechos de las mujeres ha
encontrado alternativas para potenciar
las libertades femeninas una de ellas la
creación del primer gimnasio en kandahar
exclusivo para mujeres veamos
marían durán y a sus 36 años es una
feroz defensora de los derechos
femeninos en afganistán
no sólo dirige una estación de radio
sólo para mujeres sino que recientemente
cambió de táctica para abrir el primer
gimnasio que atrae a 50 mujeres cada día
la reacción de las damas fue muy
positiva porque lo necesitaba pero
lamentablemente lo que me molestó fue la
reacción de los hombres
que sobre todo los hombres que son
educados y se creen unos intelectuales
estos hombres fueron los que
reaccionaron negativamente a nuestro
club e incluso me insultaron porque
pensaban que nuestro gimnasio estaba en
oposición a la sharía
cuando los talibanes gobernaron el país
en 1996 y 2001 las mujeres tuvieron
prohibida la educación y salir a la
calle sin pariente masculino aunque
ahora se tienen más libertades muchas
mujeres siguen siendo escépticas más aún
con la retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses tras la firma de paz
entre el gobierno local y su grupo
talibán
tenemos una cultura muy tradicional y
cerrada que es un desafío para nosotras
la pobreza económica el analfabetismo de
las mujeres y la preocupación por la
seguridad son los otros desafíos que
enfrentamos tenemos muchos problemas en
nuestra zona porque después de muchos
años de estar en silencio nuevamente
estamos luchando por encontrar los
derechos de las mujeres y esta lucha
lleva mucho tiempo por lo pronto este
club está enfocado en recibir nuevamente
a las mujeres empleadas y amas de casa
especialmente después del confinamiento
que mantuvo el gimnasio cerrado tres
meses de un éter sojeras es sin duda uno
viene aquí con miedo y todo el mundo
sabe que en tal situación las mujeres
tenemos más miedos pero si lo miramos
desde otro ángulo el ejercicio es
beneficio
para nuestra salud y por lo tanto trae
felicidad para centrarse más en nuestras
metas e ignorar nuestros miedos gracias
al trabajo de durán y en el 2012 la
entonces primera dama de eeuu michelle
obama le entregó el premio internacional
de mujeres valientes un premio que le ha
incentivado a seguir con su lucha en uno
de los países más restrictivos del mundo
para ser mujer
vamos a áfrica en sudán del sur fuertes
inundaciones tienen al país ahogado en
una crisis humanitaria desde que en
julio se incrementaron las lluvias se
cuentan cerca de 600.000 personas
desplazadas de acuerdo con la onu luego
de que la cuenca del río nilo se
desbordara organismos internacionales
aúnan esfuerzos para apoyar a las miles
de familias pobres en un país que apenas
se está recuperando de una guerra civil
de 5 años y bajo el acechante avance del
cobi 19 en áfrica los detalles en el
siguiente informe
el río nilo desbordado
cultivos arrasados
y la gente con el agua hasta las
rodillas
este es el panorama en sudan del sur
luego de los meses de torrenciales
lluvias que han dejado a más de 600.000
personas desplazadas de acuerdo con
cifras de la organización de las
naciones unidas
aquí tenemos una situación de
inundaciones e inseguridad alimentaria
ya esto le agregas el cob y 19 buscan
tes
en algunos de estos condados también se
ha experimentado un gran aumento de la
violencia cuatro problemas juntos para
el cual las comunidades y las familias
están ampliando su capacidad con que
hacerles friendly's my life is ending
los científicos de las naciones unidas
han dicho que la inusual ola invernal de
estos meses ha sido causada por un
patrón climático cíclico que ha sido
exacerbado por el cambio climático
joe la mayoría de los lugares donde la
gente ha sido desplazada se parecen a
esta escuela se inundaron todas las
áreas e incluso la agricultura los
cultivos y los animales se han ido los
ganaderos sobrevivimos gracias a los
animales y a las cosechas pero debido a
este desastre natural ahora no tenemos
nada
la crisis de desplazados ha obligado a
miles de familias apretujarse en
refugios donde la posibilidad de
contraer el virus de kobe 19 es bastante
alta o en su defecto personas como coco
mayor de 70 años que se encuentran
durmiendo bajo los árboles luego de huir
de su aldea con sus nietos
vinimos de un lugar lejano llamado
acudir hacia este pueblo de duch el
nivel del agua llegaba a la mitad de mi
cuerpo y aquí en tu está seco estamos
aquí ahora sin refugios para mí y mis
nietos como la onu asigna un presupuesto
de 10 millones de dólares para ayudar a
las víctimas de las inundaciones pero
advierte que se requieren 40 millones
más para cubrir las necesidades de aquí
a final de año
en argentina se vive desde el 2018 una
fuerte recesión económica que ha
afectado a miles de personas la
problemática se ha agravado en el 2020
con la pandemia de coronavirus por lo
cual el país se encamina a una
contracción del 12% elevando los niveles
de pobreza y desempleo uno de los
indicadores de lo que pasa en argentina
está relacionado con la imposibilidad de
pagar el alquiler y con la consecuente
migración de personas hacia el campo a
continuación la historia
a las afueras de gernika un pasaje
campesino en la provincia de buenos
aires- decenas de argentinos se tomaron
un pastizal baldío de 98 hectáreas para
levantar allí carpas y chozas
improvisadas se trata de personas que a
lo largo del 2020 han tenido que
abandonar sus casas porque el dinero ya
no les alcanza como es el caso de
gonzalo esquivel pintor de oficio no
puede pagar más bien killer trabajo en
negro es el pintor y nadie por la
pandemia me quedé sin trabajo y no puedo
pagar más alquiler me queden a valle
porque mis cositas fui vendiendo para
dar para el alquiler hasta de eso me
nada fui vendiendo mis propios muebles
mi tele mis cosas para irme guarde mi
heladera y una cosita para una casa
donde un amigo mío y yo estoy acá desde
el primer día que se hizo la toma de
este agua porque no tengo adónde ir como
gonzalo la mayoría de personas
desalojadas de sus hogares comenzaron a
llegar a este lugar en el mes de julio
para entonces argentina todavía estaba
bajo un estricto bloqueo razón por la
cual el comercio estaba congelado en
consecuencia la tasa de desempleo del
segundo trimestre del año se situó
en 14% lo que representa alrededor de
400.000 personas sin trabajo
necesitaba un lugar fijo para poder
tener mi familia mi nena y porque quizás
tengo un día de trabajo y al otro día no
pero no tengo para pagar alquiler pero
no tengo nada para comer yo en argentina
hay alrededor de 3.6 millones de
familias afectadas por la falta de
vivienda según datos del gobierno lo que
se traduce en un aumento de ocupaciones
de terrenos baldíos como es el caso de
gernika un problema que enfrenta a la
población civil con las autoridades
quienes buscan desalojarlos por
infringir la ley
y finalizamos en lo alto de los andes
bolivianos donde varios indígenas
quemaron ofrendas en honor a la
pachamama la denominada por ellos diosa
de la fertilidad diosa de la tierra como
parte de los rituales que le rinden los
pueblos nativos andinos antes del
equinoccio de la primavera del
hemisferio sur para los líderes de esta
comunidad las ofrendas de este año
cuentan con un carácter especial pues se
enmarcan en la pandemia el coronavirus
por tanto piden que bolivia reactivar su
economía prontamente así como la
agricultura revive su cadena de
producción sobre estas imágenes nos
despedimos esta es la semana de los más
vulnerables en el mundo ustedes
recuerden que pueden ver esta y otras
informaciones en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom
[Música]